c'est un rêve brisé l'équipe de France
s'arrête en quart de finale de sa coupe
du monde au Stade de France après cette
défaite face à l'Afrique du Sud d'un
tout petit point 29 à 28 on y a cru les
Bleus ont brillé par moment on fait
beaucoup d'erreur et cela se paye Fabien
Galtier n'aura pas réussi son Paris nous
sommes en direct dans les studios du
Figaro Laurent Louette bonsoir Carl mus
Jean-Christophe buisson François Aubel
bon première réaction
Christophe la détresse totale détresse
totale c'est tellement deux matchs
différents entre la première et deième
mi-temps la première qui était
spectaculaire maîtrisée venant et la la
seconde on l'impression qu'il y a
quelque chose qui s'est grippé dans la
machine al c'est les Sud-Africains qui
nous ont fait déjouer ça c'est évident
il y a quand même pardon de revenir
là-dessus mais des décisons d'arbitrage
qui paraissent quand même un petit peu
baroque 95 moins spectaculaire mais il y
a quand Mme é un peu douteuse je trouve
euh et puis on a manqué de moteur moi
j'étais déjà premierre mi-temps frappé
par par jeavais dit aldrit que je
trouvais pas il nous a vraiment manqué
ce moteur là d'aldrit du pont qui a qui
a pas percuté comme il faisait
d'habitude on sait pourquoi Jalibert qui
s'est réveillé en fin de match en
prenant des intervalles il y a eu plein
de petits détails comme ça qui ont qui
ont faussé le je pense la la belle
dynamique de la première mi-temps Carlus
ça fait mal au cœur oui parce que bah
comme le rappelait David RA on n jamais
mis autant de moyens pour cette équipe
de France en 4 ans en préparation en
staff
euh tout ça devait nous mener au moins
jusqu'à la demi-finale voir la finale et
et on perd en quart de finale c'est les
face au champion du monde et comme dit
Jean-Christophe buisson on a vu deux
deux équipes de France une équipe de
France qui maîtriser son sujet en prière
mi-temps h HM et en deuxième mi-temps
une pression des Sud-Africains qui nous
a empêché de développer notre jeu chaque
fois qu'Antoine Dupont passait le ballon
d'abord il avait des hésitations ce qui
est assez rare je pense qu'effectivement
il était fatigué où il y avait quelque
chose où c'était pas dans de bonnes
conditions mais ensuite quand le 10 le
11 ou le 12 récupérait le ballon et ben
il y avait un sudafricain qui lui qui
était dessus donc on a difficilement pu
mettre en place notre jeu l'arbitrage
Antoine lupont on va revenir évidemment
sur tous ces sujets Laurent Louette
votre premier sentiment là 5 minutes
après le coup de sifflé final et cette
défaite des Bleus c'est la cruauté du
sport de très haut niveauou ça se joue à
un petit point d'écart on a vu qu'il y
avait en première mi-temps des points
que l'équipe de France avait laissé
filer on a vu qu'en 2ième mi-temps elle
redémarrait à 15 contre 14 puisque et or
lorsque hzebet est rentré au bout de 10
minutes les 10 minutes de son de sa
période en bunker l'équipe de France
n'avait pas fait évoluer le score on
était resté on était toujours à
2219 et et quand on regarde les stades
de fin de match on s'aperçoit que
justement sur les 15 premières minutes
les les Sud-Africains ont redémarré très
très fort en en certainement conscient
de leur infériorité numérique avec
l'idée justement de pouvoir de gérer ce
ce supposé tempfit pour c'est raté vous
avez raison ce petit point d'écart et
les points perdus on pense et c'est pas
de sa faute d'une certaine manière mais
cette transformation contrite de Thomas
Ramos c'est voilà François votre
réaction avant qu'on rentre dans le
détail moi je ventre non Erasmus a fait
rentrer fa de clerc surtout qui a fait
rentrer fouri il a fait rentrer pogas
Smith et c'est à mon avis eux qui sont
allés gagner le match dans la bataille
des rcks ils nous ont pourri tous les
ballons il y a pas un ballon qui est
sorti correctement Carl disait que
Antoine Dupont hésité à sortir les
ballons il était gêné à toutes les
sorties on le voyait bien il était gêné
parce qu'ils sont allés chicailler tous
les ballons ils sont allés nous ils ont
gagné la bataille des Rocks sur cette
deuxème mi-temps ils avaient gagné la
bataille aérienne sur la première ils
ont B gagner la la bataille des rcks et
voilà et ça et
effectivement je suis assez d'accord
avec Jean-Christophe je trouve que le
tracteur aldrit avait à mon avis été
très fatigué ça ça se voyait ça avançait
pas suffisamment donc voilà le coup de
poker de d'Erasmus a fonctionné he faire
rentrer on va on va y revenir aussi
parce que vous nous avvez annoncé que
c'était probablement une une tactique et
un choix très réfléchi de de la part des
Sud-Africains on va au Stade de France
Vincent reoseron on imagine que tout à
coup au coup de les finale le stade s
tue c'est bien
ça et ben effectivement par rapport à ce
à quoi ressemble ce stade de France
habituellement après un match deéquipe
de France remporté comme depuis le début
de la compétition et ben là ce n'est pas
le cas vous le voyez derrière moi
peut-être beaucoup de gens quittent le
stade pas pas trop le cœur à la joie et
forcément l'équipe de France a perdu
l'équipe de France est éliminé de sa
coupe du monde et c'est bien triste
Jean-Marc oui je dois souligner quand
même quelque chose que j'ai trouvé assez
désagréable de la part du du public
français c'est une bronca sifflet au
coup de sifflet
final il faut être beau joueur quoi
qu'il arrive les sud-africain ont gagné
tout à fait à la
régulière voilà on peut toujours dire
que l'arbitre était commeci ou comme
çaf mais le reste de du truc j'ai
entendu à l'instant François qui disait
par exemple que il y a quelques joueurs
qui avaient sousperformé notamment
aldrit c'était clair depuis dès le
début Jean-Marc Gonin lui aussi Figaro
Magazine merci Jean-Marc d'être avec
nous tiens je vous sens ému l'équipe de
France ne sera encore pas championne du
monde c'est une compétition qui se
refuse au bleu jusqu'à
quand c'est c'est la malédiction de du
Stade de France en de jours vous avez
les Irlandais qui ne franchissent jamais
l'écart et les Français qui qui ne
gagnent pas la Coupe du
monde avec une génération exceptionnelle
qui que tout le monde enfin que beaucoup
donn les favorites ouais on imagine on
le sent Jean-Marc c'est toujours
différent quand on est au stade on a
cette euphorie pendant plusieurs minutes
qui s'ffondre d'un coup Jean-Christophe
oui c'est c'est encore pire quand on est
sur place je plains nos amis qui qui
sont là-bas mais mais cela dit je pense
qu'il y a quelques je sais pas 10 15 20
millions de Français qui sont aussi
catastrophés parce que c'est vrai que
tout tout était écrit un peu à l'avance
alors peut-être qu'on s'est vu trop beau
encore une fois moi je pense que sur le
papier on est vraiment au niveau de
l'Afrique du Sud et même au-dessus mais
euh je suis je suis étonné que Jean-Marc
soit si euh si euh clément avec l'AR
clément avec l'arbitrage vraiment euh
alors enfin en tout cas c'est sur sur
l'écran des télévision on voyait des
tous les RCK était quand même pourri
avec des parfois il montaaiit sur les il
montaient sur les passes mais ils
étaient hors jeu mais c'était évident
sur les rocks vraiment il y a des
décisions d'arbitrage qui peuvent être
pris dans un sens ou dans l'autre et qui
sont toujours prises dans le sens des
des
sudaf vous nêtes pas d'accord pour vous
c'est d'abord une erreur des Bleus avant
de critiquer
l'arbitrage non mais je comprends ce que
JeanChristophe dit je partage ce
sentiment là mais je déteste
mettre en cause l'arbitrage dans une
dans une défaite c'est mon quand je
faisais du sport jamais je ne je
jeallais mettre en cause un arbitre je
n'aime pas faire ça mais oui on peut
dire que benokif a laissé passer des des
fautes que que ce que dit Jean
Jean-Christophe les rcks pourris les les
gens qui ét qui venaient dans qui
venaient chez nous les les les
Sud-Africains qui venaient chez nous
pour pourrir les sorties oui le plan
était clair c'était fait pour ça c'était
un plan antidupon mais pas pour pour lui
casser la figure comme tout le monde
disait mais pour l'empêcher de jouer
pour d'aller vite on l'a vu énormément
ralenti et surt enfin vous le disit en
plateau aussi au début c'est que c'est
cette deuxième mi-temps avec cette
nouvelle charnière qui rentre et qui
change complètement le la physionomie du
match absolument parce qu'au début du
match je sais pas j'ai pas regardé le
chronomètre
mais j'avais jamais vu les Sud-Africains
se faire manger comme ça jamais je veux
dire au près au large c'était il y avait
une puissance française moi j'ai jamais
vu un pack des boxes mal mené à ce point
peut-être une fois ou deux par les par
les Blacks mais j'ai jamais vu le Spring
Box dans cet étatl il doutaiit
complètement et là on parle une heure
après et
malheureusement les boxes ont ont
surrelé la tête jeanchist vous êtes pas
d'accord avec ce que dit Jean-Marc oui
on peut critiquer l'arbitrage non mais
je dis Jean-Marc bien sûr quand on est
sur le terrain on n pas critiqué
l'arbitre mais il se trouve que nous on
commmente donc on regarde on observe et
on a le droit de constater qu'il y a
vraiment il a eu il y a eu vraiment mais
comment 95 c'est c'est malheureux enfin
saint-endré et les autres ont mis 30 ans
pour avouer que finalement effectivement
eux-mêmes comme joueurs ils ne l'ont pas
contesté à l'époque et c'est tout à fait
la gloire de ce sport mais que
aujourd'hui le temps a passé ils peuvent
dire voilà ce qui s'est passé pendant et
ben je pense que nous aujourd'hui on est
commentateur on a le droit de dire qu'il
y a des décisions d'arbitrage dans ce
match qui sont vraiment très douteuses
allez je vous propose qu'on commence par
un thème que nous dicte les internaut
sur Youtube notamment je lis Jang as
Ramos enatant de transformation nous a
couler Ramos devrait faire un stage de
foot avec Sergio Ramos le footballeur
voilà ce qu'on dit et Joe sampai qui dit
n'allez pas critiquer Ramos sur les
réseaux s'il vous plaît c'est une
question qui se pose est-ce que la faute
lui revient alors c'est dur mais en même
temps il a des responsabilités quand on
est buteur de l'équipe de France on doit
mettre les points Carl c'est très dur
parce que jusqu'ici c'est lui qui
emmenait l'équipe de France avec un taux
de réussite au pied qui était assez
exceptionnel mais sur la trans il rate
une pénalité et une transformation et
sur la transformation il est quand même
fautif de la même façon que Farel l'a
été quand il a laissé passer le le
chrono pour l'Angleterre et et donc ça
c'était une pénalité je crois n'a pas
été prise en compte là voilà c'est deux
points qui nous manquent à l'arrivée
mais bon c'est pas ces deux points qui
nous font perdre c'est c'est c'est un
ensemble et c'est là où c'est compliqué
c'est que comme le disait Jean-Marc on a
une équipe avec une génération
exceptionnelle et malgré ça on tombe
face à l'Afrique du Sud alors on va
revenir 3 ans en arrière et et sur ce
tirage au sort beaucoup trop tôt qui met
dans la même dans le même phase de de
poule les quatre meilleures équipes du
monde lesant les Anglais dans c'est
peut-être un peu tôt pour en parler mais
vous avez raison c'est une vraie
question ça viendra mais bon c'est trop
tard on va pas pleurer sur les renversé
surtout qu'aujourd'hui on va
malheureusement tous être sud-africain
la semaine prochaine je lis ce que nous
dit romain la transformation de Ramos
contrée par par Colby j'aimerais voir
quand est-ce qu'il part il est à 25 m
comment il peut contrer oui on en
parlait à la mi-temps mais c'est c'est
une question Laurent Louette Ramos
est-ce que on doit évidemment la France
ne doit pas lui tomber dessus mais il a
des responsabilités il doit faire le job
comme vous l'avez dit c'est le buteur de
l'équipe de l'équipe et c'est à lui
quiincomble la responsabilité de
transformer potentiel période de temps
fort en point ou ou et et de et de
conclure de concrétiser une une une
domination et il faut reconnaître que
voilà 5 points à l'arrivée lâché en
route c'est c'est trop c'est trop dans
un match de très haut niveau où on le
savait ça allait jouer à très très peu
de choses fr Obel la responsabilité de
Thomas Ramos non je veux pas le je veux
pas la évidemment qu'on ne veut pas
l'accabler ça c'est c'est un fait mais
comme le dit Jean-Christophe du
journalisme de regarderou j'ai j'ai pas
envie de l'accabler parce que il y a il
y a aussi des erreurs il y a aussi des
ballons pas mal protégés il y a aussi
des jeux des retours petit côté
systématiques qui ont qui ont pas
fonctionné il y
a il y a y a il y a aussi quelques
réglages dans notre jeu qui en
deème-temps enfin ils ont tout fait pour
nous pourrir le jeu et ils ont réussi
donc euh je pense pas que vu la
domination de la première mi-temps je
pense pas que c'est la faute doiv
doivent être mis sur sur Ramos non mais
ce qui est très étonnant pardon hein
mais euh c'est que dans la domination
qu'on a au début de la deuxème mi-temps
on cherche l'essai oui on ne tente
jamais le drop et ça c'est quelque chose
c'est vrai que c'est pas culturel en
France et or on se souvient de la
remontée de l'équipe de France face au
black qui démarre justement par des Dr
la maison paraî-il absent du rugby
mondial maintenant il y a eu le premier
drop de la Coupe du
Monde TR ouais et là chelseaby en
tenttin qui passe pas très loin c'est
pas sa spécialité le drop évidemment
quand il passe vous êtes le génie si ça
rate on vous dit bah il y avait un
surnom à côté mais sauf qu'à un moment
quand vous voyez que vous arrivez pas à
passer parce que devant il y a une
défense de faire il y a deux solutions
c'est le petit le
petit pi par-dessus ce que tente
euh jaliber voilà et Ramos Ramos pour
jaliber et ça peut marcher ou vous
tentez le drop et le drop c'est TR
points il y a un manque évident de
soutien sur sur la sur quandber oui il
est tout seul on retourne devant le
Stade de France et on on finit ce ce
débat sur Thomas Ramos Jean-Marc est-ce
que Thomas Ramos est d'une certaine
manière l'un des hommes à à pointer du
doigt après cette défaite
oui on peut toujours mais il fait une
très belle Coupe du Monde jusqu'ici
c'est un excellent buteur vous aviez
remarqué dans les matchs précédents
qu'il
était il bottait très tard toujours il
laessait é grarainer le chronomètre il
avait toujours un ou deux défenseurs qui
lui foncé dessus dès qu'il avit entamé
sa course donc
c'était c'était un défaut qui enfin à
mon sens c'était un défaut ça prouvait
qu'il était détendu quand il faisait
qu'il prenait pas la pression mais
néanmoins il bottait tard et puis quand
quand vous avez Colby en face de vous
que ce soit cet AER là ou l'autre RNC
c'est deux fusées on les a bien vu sur
les contre enfin sur les les essais qui
nous mett des essais sans passe pour
récupère un ballon ça va à dem000 à
l'heure nos é ils ont pas repris Ramos
s'est fait enrumer c'est clair que ces
garçonsl faut pas leur laisser euh un
diè de seconde il vut contre donc Ramos
de ce point de vue là porte la
responsabilité mais de là l'
cablé la défaite vient de lui il y a il
y a quand même plusieurs comment dire
plusieurs cadres de de l'équipe de
France qui étaient en dessous je veux
pas les les accabler mais ils étaient en
dessous de leur niveau alors que quand
on les avait vu contre le sur le dernier
match on se disait il pètent la forme
mar il
sons pas c'est la faute de qui à un
moment ou un autre on perd contre
l'Afrique du Sud alors peut-être que les
les sudafricains était plus fort
beaucoup plus fort mais il faut trouver
des responsables évidemment bah
écoutez
monsieur galetier nous a expliqué qu'il
adorait les parti d'échec ben voilà il a
été mis cheat je veux dire il y a il y a
des stratégies il y a pourisspend des
balles il y a les coup de pied aériens
où on a été très assez médiocre
les
ballon ça fait un ensemble à ce
niveau-là ça se joue quand ça se joue à
si peu de de choses vous savez il faut
pas grand-chose pour perdre on va pas
accaber toute l'équipe pour parce qu'on
a perdu d'un point c'est on aurait pu
avoir une avance plus confortable
effectivement si on avait jouer mieux
quelques coups mais on peut pas non plus
dire
queant c'est pas flagrant pas dire qu'il
y a quelqu'un qui a raté totalement son
match Jean-Christophe buisson je vais
vous libérer mais je lis ce que disent
les les gens sur les réseaux et sur you
YouTube sont d'accord avec vous
arbitrage honteux nous dit fan one euh
les sufes peuvent dire merci à l'arbitre
pour leur victoire volée voilà ce que
nous dit loï je pense que cette histoire
va monter alors c'est peut-être très
français mais la question se pose non
non je c'est pas la seule raison pour
laquelle on a perdu je remarque a raison
il y a des cadres qui ont qui ont manqué
qu'on a qu'on a déjà qu'on a déjà cité
moi j'ai trouvé que par exemple fikou
était un peu en dessous aussi la Coupe
du
Monde coupe euh fikou là aldrid sur ce
matchl Flaman Flaman et wi sont un peu
fait manger par les par les secondes
lignes en face donc duup pot encore une
fois était pas je suis sûr était pas à
100 % il n'a pas donné toute la
l'ampleur il il a eu des éclairs comme
ça mais évidemment il pas le même volume
Jalibert ça on le savait qu' serait qu'
serait pas forcément à la fête donc
évidemment que c'est plein de petits
détails mais honnêtement moi moi je
reste quand même sur le deuxème essai de
l'Afrique du Sud qui est marqué alors
que il y a une faute d' best dans la
dans la phase précédente qui aurait dû
valoir une pénalité pour la France on
passe d'une pénalité qui n'est pas
sifflée un essai des sudafricain pardon
mais plus tous les rocks qui quand même
étaient contestables à la fin ça fait
quand même beaucoup de choses donc il y
a vraiment une forme d'amertu mais de
enfin chez moi en tout cas j'ai
vraimentis très souvent des histoires
merci Jean-Christophe Bisson merci
d'être venu avec nous sur ce plateau je
vous libère je sais que vous avez des
émissions à à préparer pour le Figaro
mais alors je veux qu'on reste sur cette
question de l'arbitrage parce que
vraiment c'est ce qui ce qui fait parler
Laurent Louette c'est quand même
régulier les Bleus qui se font voler je
me souviens de cette finale face au
néozélandais il y a quelques années
bon ça peut devenir frustrant vous voyez
ce que je veux dire oui oui j'entends
bien et j'entends bien que sur le coup
de la
déception il est facile de désigner un
coupable surtout lorsqu'il est habillé
en noir et blanc comme l'était monsieur
comme l'était l'arbitre ce soir mais
mais franchement très sincèrement c'est
également très français de de de
désigner l'arbitre comme le principal
responsable de tous nos mots mais mais
Fran mais sincèrement ce soir que j'ai
lancé un sondage sur Youtube l'arbitre
a-t-il été à la hauteur dans cette
rencontre oui ou non on va voir ce qu'on
pense aux internautes moi en deuxième
mi-temps je n'ai pas vu de d'action
extrêmement précise et qui
ont provoqué une décision d'arbitre qui
a fait pencher le match c'est pas moi ce
n'est pas ce que j'ai vu je n'ai pas vu
de décision d'arbitre litigieux qui ont
fait basculer le match j'ai vu j'ai vu
un pé à tomom vaca lorsqu'il est sorti
manquer cruellement au 15 de France
qui devant à
souff souffer d'un d'un leader j'ai vu
une charnière du pont jaliber qui en
2uxè mi-temps n'a pas pris les reenes du
match n'a pas su apporter une réponse à
la domination des des Springbox devant
j'ai vu un Ramos qui a failli en
première mi-temps dans son rôle de
buteur en laissant échapper 5 points qui
nous manque cruellement à l'arrivée bon
voilà je n'ai pas vu un arbitre faire
pencher le match en faveur des spring je
lis ce que nous dit Vincent maill trop
facile de jouer gentleman sur
l'arbitrage quand l'arbitre fait du sale
et souvent pour la même équipe faut le
dire voilà et on a des gens en colère
oui c'est normal parce que on espéit
beaucoup de cette équipe de France mais
après il faut pas non plus comparer 2023
à 1995 ENF 19 9 c'était en Afrique à la
finale de c'était finale c'était oui
voilà on était dans c'était des
contextes
différents je je rebondis sur ce que
disait Jean-Marc Gonin il a je pense
entièrement raison de de citer Fabien
Galtier parce que la réalité c'est que
dans une partie d'échec il faut prévoir
des stratégies de rechange et on on a
bien vu qu'elle était la première
stratégie de Fabien Galtier qui s'est
déroulé en première mi-temps avec une
réponse sur l'agressivité une domination
mais il n'a pas su s'adepter au
changement de
stratégie du coach
sud-africain en deè mi-temps que on a
essayé de faire la même chose et on peut
se demander je pense que la question
viendra est-ce qu'il aurait pas dû
sortir Antoine Dupont à un moment du
match allez on y vient on a abordé pour
ceux qui nous re Ramos plutôt pour gérer
au pied parce que il y a pas du tout de
gestion on n'est pas allé jouer chez eux
on n pas on est on av on avait si points
d'avance on pouvait quand même aller
jouer chez eux pouvez aller exactement
c'est ce que j'appelle le plan B
François pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
on a abordé évidemment cette déception
vous n'hésitez pas vous nous le dites
sur Figaro.fr sur Youtube votre
sentiment après cette défaite d'un tout
petit point en quart de finale de la
Coupe du Monde on a parlé de Thomas
Ramos on a parlé de l'arbitrage on a
parlé des erreurs il est peut-être temps
d'ouvrir déjà le dossier galetier est-ce
que Jean-Marc
Gonin c'est sa faute ce soir en partie
en tout cas est-ce qu'il a il s'est raté
lui aussi
oui je pense aussi ce que Carl a dit me
me convient très bien moi je crois qu'il
a il a pas modifié sa
stratégie contrairement à ce qu'on fait
les Sud Africains qu'il avait même
anticipé le changement de stratégie en
mettant des cadres importants sur le
banc donc ils savaient pertinemment que
eux allaient jouer différemment et il y
a des il y a des choses que que la
France pratique fort bien pratiqué toute
cette coupe du monde et que là on n pas
vu les très longs coups de pied de
Ramous les les les repousser en fond de
terrain on on l'a fait très peu
euh ball oui on avait la possession du
ballon on a on a vraiment beaucoup de
choses qui manquaient à à à l'équipe de
France à celle qu'on a qu'on a vu ces
dernières semaines donc il a de ce point
de vue-l galetier devait devait revoir
sa copie mais c'est galetier donc ça il
a un côté j'ai raison qui B on le
connait on le connaît ça fait quelques
années qu'il est dans le circuit c'est
un
type extrêmement intelligent qui sent le
rugby mais qui connaî ce sport
admirablement mais qui parfois peut-être
se sent trop
fort et c'est d'autant plus curieux que
il connaît bien le RBY africains pour y
avoir
joué c'est ça qui frustrant parce qu'il
les il les a vu venir il il les a vu
venir enfin il en rigolait même il
disait que cé ça allait c'était
stratégiquement cétait visible pour lui
sauf que sur le terrain il y a pas eu de
traduction il a pas bougé et et c'est
vrai ce que dis JeanMarc moi je je
comprends pas qu'on est pas géré qu'on
est fait sortir peut-être Jalibert un
peu plus tôt qu'on se soit adapté ou que
du pont peut-être qu'il aurait fallu le
sortir un peu plus tôt mais après mais
alors c'est toujours facile contre la
Namibie vous étiez ici et vous me ditz
non il fallait pas le sortir plutôt
parce qu'il est capable d'un coup de
génie bonah voilà on l' on l'a senti
cramer en
deè oui mais contre la on sentait le
match gagné voyez ce que je veux dire
après coup c'est toujours facile il y a
quand même des joueurs qui ont illuminé
cette partie
patomovaka
Olivon flamand était très bon dans le
combat il le sort
alors
taofuna apporte sa masse mais flamand on
peut jouer derrière lui plus facilement
onio avant de sortir a été très bon
atonio on pouvait jouer derrière lui il
passait les bras ce que fait flamand on
n pas allé jouer derrière cette défense
on est on est resté collé devant la
défense
mais je trouve que Jean-Marc a utilisé
une
expression tout à fait vraie lorsquil
parle lorsqu'il dit que Galtier a été
mis échec et mat je crois que je crois
qu'on peut se regarder et se dire
effectivement de notre côté il y a eu
des faillites en effet chez les joueurs
sur le plan technique au niveau
stratégique mais en face il y a une
équipe championne du monde avec un duo
de coach qui a fait le Paris de mettre
en place une stratégie au départ oui
différente de qui nous a interrogé qui
est différ qui était différente de celle
sur lesquelles on on les attendait c'est
une équipe championne du monde donc qui
a des certitudes qui est reconnu dans le
monde entier pour un style de jeu auquel
elle a en partie tourné le dos a renoncé
oui pendant 45 minutes et en deuxème
mi-temps ces finisherss sont revenus à
un jeu effectivement qui ressemblait
davantage au jeux sud-africain oui ce
que vous dites c'est on aurait dû faire
la différence en première mi-temps avant
de se faire reprendre par ouais je
comprends c'est ce que je dis depuis le
départ on a laissé passer laissé
échapper des points au départ et et en
début de 2è mi-temps lorsqu'on avait
l'occasion à 14 contre 15 de d'enfoncer
le clou on n pas su le faire en 10
minutes en 10 minutes on est resté à 22
à la mi-temps on est content de basculer
avec TR points d'avance sauf que on doit
se dire ce que vous nous disiez François
depuis le début du match attention à la
50e minute changement et c'est l'équipe
type qui revient sur le terrain ou en
tout cas les les meneurs bah les meneurs
vous avez même vu que le jeu
sud-africain c'est accéléré c'est allé
beaucoup plus vite ils étaient beaucoup
plus sur les points de contact ils
étaient là beaucoup plus vite qu'au
début et et surtout il il fait pas
rentrer que fa de clerc et
poarde à la 60e il vide son banc oui
colissi qui sort le capitaine qui sort
il il met pog sm la 50e la 50e
ouais c'est Pogy Smith qui rentre Pogy
Smith il met met les mains partout il va
il va pourrir le jeu donc c'était prévu
enfit quand on voit sortir ça c'est ça
que je comprends pas h qu'onarrive pas à
s'adapter alors que c'est quand même
écrit mais al c'est depuis vend depuis
la composition de l'équipe on le sait et
on ne sait pas adapter c'est ça qui est
incompréhensible je donne le résultat de
du premier sondage lancé sur Youtube
l'arbitre a-t-il été à la hauteur dans
cette rencontre non à 64 % voilà ce
qu'on pense nos nos internautes on
parlait de galetier Jean-Marc en quoi
a-t-il failli qu'est-ce qu'il aurait dû
faire différemment le sélectionneur des
des Bleus même si on ne l'AC cable pas
même si on peut lui trouver des causes
atteignuantes c'était lui qui devait
faire des choix qu'a-t-il
raté c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on vient t
tous de dire plus ou moins c'est-à-dire
que on pouvait revenir à des
fondamentaux des choses que qu' qu'on
faisait mieux euh il y avait peut-être
des changements à effectués parce que il
a quelques vraiment des des cadres qui
étaient en dessous je l'ai déjà dit mais
c'est il y avait il y a des gens qui ont
vraiment sousperformés des joueurs
sousperformés on a nommé it mais il y en
a d'autres et voilà essentiellement ça
essentiellement ça alors pour répondre
sur l'histoire de l'arbitre comme la
dernière fois que ça s'est mal passé
avec l'Afrique du Sud vous les plus
anciens comme moi se souviennent que le
l'arbitre du match scandaleux a reçu une
montre en or sud-africaine donc pour
trancher la question on va voir si beno
kif a droit à sa montre
bientôt oui vous avez raison bon ne
soyez pas trop mauvaise langue Jean-Marc
Gonin je réponds quand même à Patrick
Birot les mecs sur les plateau sont fort
pour dire ce que doit faire Galtier mais
incapable de dire un mot sur l'arbitre
et bien il fallait arriver plutôt parce
qu'on l'a fait mon cher mon cher Patrick
d'ailleurs les internautes se sont
exprimé sur la question j'ai relancé un
sondage Fabien Galtier est-il le grand
responsable de cette défaite Carl je
vous ai pas trop entendu sur Fabien
Galtier bah si c'est je vous ai dit
justement qu'il avait pas réussi à
répondre au défis lancé par les est
responsable oui d'accord là sur ce oui
en tant que sélectionnaire évidemment il
est
responsable à mon avis il se cache sera
pas derrière son petit doigt il assumera
la responsabilité parce
que comme l'a dit David au début de de
notre r transansmission on lui a donné
des moyens que jamais un autre
sélectionnaire n'a eu avant lui il a eu
un staff plétorique il a eu les joueurs
à sa disposition pour faire tourner il a
eu comme toutes les autres équipes un du
temps pour préparer ses joueurs mais
voilà il était là on était là où où on
devait être on a terminé premier de la
poule tout ça c'était parfait on savait
que on pouvait on allait affronter les
Sud-Africains mais il a pas su adapter
notre jeu il a pas su
changer soit un Jalibert soit un Dupon
ou ou recentrer il a pas su dire au aux
joueurs si vous n'arvez pas à franchir
la ligne d'essai essayez le drop tentez
des choses resserreer le jeu comme dit
jean-margonin et c'est en ce sens-là que
oui il a une part de responsabilité oui
merci de de de l'évoquer comme tel parce
que me revient à l'esprit des images que
j'ai que j'ai vu dans sur youtube il y a
une excellente série qui qui est un peu
les yeux dans les Bleus hein dans les
coulisses du 15 de France et me revient
une interview de d'Antoine Dupont il y a
deux ou trois semaines qui évoquait le
rapport et les clés du jeu que leur
remettait Fabien Galtier et Dupon
expliquait Queen fait dans les
situations dans les moments
difficiles lorsqu'il était au commande
du cas de France il avait la capacité à
à trouver une réponse pour inverser le
sens du jeu au profit du 15 de France
grâce au ressorts et aux clés
stratégiques que lui que que donnait
Fabien Galtier depuis qu'il était aux
commandes du 15 de France et là en
l'occurrence en 2uxème mi-temps ça s'est
pas produit d pont il les a pas trouvé
ces ces clés-là en tout cas euh moi je
les ai pas vu j'ai pas vu un Dupon
d'abord que j'ai trouvé amoindri
physiquement euh rapidement voilà autour
de la dès que les les finisherss
Sud-Africains sont sont et Declerc qui
rentré il a souffert de la comparaison
et ensuite il a pas trouvver le le
ressort tactique pour pour permettre au
15 de France de s' ce qui est terrible
c'est que le score est de 28 29 un point
le même match avec par exemple cette
transformation de Ramos non contré et
qui passe entre les poteaux le même
match Fabien Galtier est un génie absolu
c'est c'est le sport de très oui oui
Jean-Marc Gonin bon on va pas refaire
toute l'histoire du sport et et
philosopher là-dessus mais c'est quand
même à chaque fois hallucinant de se
dire ça
oui euh fait de se dire qu'on aurait pu
gagner en il nous manque quelques points
qu'on qu'on aurait facilement pu pu
marquer c'est ce que vous voulez me dire
euh oui et surtout euh voilà je vous je
vous demande pre d'être de vous élever
au-dessus du Stade de France et de me
parler de la glorieuse incertitude du
sport Jean-Marc
oui ça alors là on philosophe vraiment
mais oui c'est aussi c'esti pourquoi on
aime le sport parce qu'il comporte des
des défaites et des victoires mais là
faut dire que on voit la f sorti la
moitié des colibet sont pour sont pour
l'arbitre les gens on du mal à digérer
l'affaire mais ce qui vient d'être dit
par Laurent je crois sur sur Galtier me
semble pertinent en plus je crois qu'il
a voulu faire cette partie d'échec
précisément contre sirasmen qui est une
grande gueule du du rugby et et qui qui
est aussi un type assez exceptionnel et
il voulait vraiment le battre aux échecs
il il a vécu il l'a connu en Afrique du
Sud ils se connaissent et je pense que
c'était aussi c'était aussi une une
espèce de victoire qui qui voulait pour
lui et il incarne ce projet comme disait
Carl de A jusqu'à Z même Galtier c'est
c'est c'est son Poulin c'est son enfant
c'est donc euh euh pardon euh Dupon
c'est son Poulin c'est son enfant donc
tout tout le cadre de cette équipe c'est
lui et il va être obligé de le
justifieré maintenant en conférence de
presse et on sait comme il est courageux
et bravache il il le fera probablement
assez bien mais euh effectivement euh
avec tous les moyens qu'il a eu de la
part de la Ligue de la part de la
fédération et c'est un échec c'est une
grosse baffe quoi ouais Vincent roseron
juste une question parce que j'entends
du bruit derrière vous comment ça se
passe j'imagine que les ce sont les
Sud-Africains qui chante est-ce que
l'ambiance reste bon enfant
effectivement ah oui très très bon
enfant en fait on vient de voir un
cortège sudafricain qui vient de passer
avec des percussions en chantant qui
alors c'est juste en dessous de nous en
fait parce qu'on est on est en haut du
drambarde et en dessous de nous il y a
des gens qui passent et c'est là où ça
chante beaucoup sinon on va pas se
mentir l'ambiance est quand même assez
calme le long tout au long du Stade de
France c'est quand même vraiment très
très calme
Springbox
att poser question
question je poser oui alors oui
effectivement qu'est-ce que vous voulez
poser comme
question on a combien de temps pour lui
poser une
question vous avez tout le temps que
vous voulez mon
ch loose balls and we justing
rugby
ok than donc ils ont joué comme les
Spring Box savent le faire et ils ont
gagné en gros c'est ce qu' à peu près
ouais oui ou c'est c'est de là-bas le
football se joue à 11 et c'est
l'Allemagne qui gagne vous êtes en train
de me dire que ce sont les les Spring
Box qui le font tiens l'ambiance Vincent
dans dans ce stade grande ambiance
grande soirée comment ça s'est passé en
en fin de match d'un seul coup j'imagine
ce moment de
décompression alors on pour de la fin du
match de la fin du match et ben oui
alors je je vais pas laisser Jean marque
en parler de la dernière dernière minute
parce que moi je je sors du stade juste
avant la fin ce qu'on ce qu'on sentait
c'est quand même une grosse tension qui
s mis en place sur les 20 dernières
minutes vraiment un voilà on on on était
on était
devant de plusieurs points et tout d'un
coup on a senti que le vent pouvait
tourner pour moi il y a il y a un moment
charnière qui est cette pénalité de
jaliber qui est complètement dévissé qui
tape dans nos 22 et là on se dit ah ça
peut pe très très mal tourné B déjà le
pied de Jalibert a très mal tourné mais
la fin du match a mal tourné aussi oui
oui et puis a j'étais hier ici hier soir
pour le pour
l'Irlande Nouvelle-Zélande et il y a
alors les match sont assez différents ou
Nouvelle-Zélande les matchs étaient
assez différents mais alors les les les
10 dernières minutes sont à peu près une
copie conforme c'est-à-dire que les
Irlandais ne passaient plus perdaient
leur leur jeu il y avait des des
initiatives désordonnées et puis on
voyait dans le regard des joueurs qu'ils
étaient perdus y compris les comment
dire les les vrais cadres comme comme la
France et pas seulement sextone mais on
voyait leurs meilleurs éléments savait
plus où aller sur le banc c'était la
dévastation et le public doucement
s'éteignit Vincent attention nos
internautes se méfi et tente de vous
protéger Joe qui nous dit j'ai cru qu'il
allait embrasser le journaliste avec le
micro faites attention à à vos amis
derrière vous je rends compte du sondage
lancé il y a quelques instants
oui allez-y
Jean-Marc non non je dis le quand il est
effectu le Sud-Africain peut être
dangereux qu oui on l'a bien vu Fabien
gtier est-il le grand responsable de
cette défaite c'est non pour 73 % des
internautes du du Figaro Antoine Dupont
c'était la le joueur sur lequel tous les
yeux se posaient depuis bien longtemps
mais encore un peu plus depuis 3
semaines a-t-il pu peser ce soir il a
fait une très bonne première mi-temps
François non ouais il a fait une très
bonne première mi-temps mais en deuxème
mi-temps il s'est fait totalement
étouffé je le disais euh avant avant ce
match que la la la tactique des
Sud-Africains serait de nous asixier et
ils sont allés à la tout de suite au
coup et le le coup l'organe vital de du
15 de France c'est Antoine Dupont et ils
sont allés lui lui faire pourrir et dé
jouer les ballons ils les ont tous
ralentis voilà non ce qui m'embête c'est
que ça nous place encore dans dans ce
dans cette dans cette position de de
loser magnifique qui moi commence à me à
m'ennuyer passablement et et au-delà de
ça et j'en parle parce que je suis en
face de Carl mus et qui s'occupe de la
politique ce qui est fou c'est que
Macron avait lié son destin Antoine
Dupont il est allé le voir à Castello
magoac il connaît bien son père ils sont
des des des Hautes Pyrénées tous les
deux ils ont la famille là-bas et je
trouve que dans la séquence qu'est-ce
que vous êtes en train de me dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron doit démissionner non
non non non je trouve que la séquence
est pas que la séquence pour lui est pas
bonne avec cette en plus cette défaite
de l'équipe de France et voilà de d'être
les losers magnifiques parce que
quelques part on a eu du panache en
première mi-temps qu'on se soit pas
adapté en seconde et c'est vraiment ça
nous colle à la peau ça c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui c'est vrai qu'en
tant qu'amateur de rugby cette défaite
cette défaite elle nous fait mal pour
les gens qui aiment le rugby parce qu'en
plus c'est une deuxième compétition qui
commence avec les matchs à élimination
directe c'est dire que en première sur
la les 8 semaines que dur une coupe du
monde de rugby les les premières
semaines à l'occasion du premier tour
c'est l'occasion pour les officiion do
les gens qui aiment le rugby de se
mobiliser de regarder les les résultats
en détail et puis et puis d'attendre la
suite mais alors ces matchs élimination
directe et force quand une équipe de
France commence à performer ils
embarquent au-delà de la famille de du
sport la discipline en question c'est
tout un pays qui est-ce que ils ont le
temps de le faire les Français du quart
de France pas sûr quart de finale c'est
un peu tôt pour embarquer tout un pays
non en tout cas l'embarqué le match
d'ouverture vous PL mais regardez les
chiffres d'audience de T vra c'est vrai
un mauvais coup pour t en tout cas c'est
un mauvais coup pour non non les
Français étaient là non mais ce que je
veux dire audience mais j'entends bien
car ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on ne
Rav ce 15 de France il passe à côté de
l'opportunité de raviver la nostalgie de
France 98 ce pays qui s'emballe autour
d'une équipe de
France il avait un super coup à jouer et
c'est très frustrant aujourd'hui deux
choses à vous dire la blessure d'Antoine
DUP a-t-elle influé sur le résultat du
match c'est le nouveau sondage que je
viens de lancer et puis alors une petite
information euh et je pense que cette
image va beaucoup tourner là dans les
minutes qui viennent et demain il y a
évidemment des gens qui ont essayé de
décrypter ce qu'il s'était passé sur la
transformation de Thomas Ramos Colby est
parti avant il est parti avant le
mouvement de avant que Ramos n'engage sa
course C exactement ben ça normalement
il y a un arbitrage vidéo qui doit
pouvoir vérifier çaain hein c'est pas
c'est pas normal voilà mais de sur ces
quart de finale il y a un problème
d'arbitrage sur toute cette Coupe du
Monde on en a reparlé avec David R il y
a des problèmes d'arbitrage qui sont pas
cohérents il a pas un match qui
arbitrait pareil et voilà aucun match
qui arbitrait pareil sur on l'a dit tout
à l'heure etzebet qui tape le ballon
l'arbitre dit non c'est en arrière il y
a rien bah
le le bout des Doig et lui il a un
carton jaune sur des coups à la tête
c'est pas arbitré de la même façon donc
c'est c'est un peu problématique on on a
aucune raison de remettre en cause les
les l'étude des gens qui ont regardé sur
leur s'ils le disent c'est que c'est
probablement vrai mais si c'est vrai
c'est un cas d'espèce qui qui peut se
révéler
extrêmement grave au sens où oui grave
toute proportion gardée à l'chelle du
rugby on parle de rugby on est dans un
débrief d'un match de Coupe du Monde bon
mais ça peut être un un sujet qui qui
peut dans l'univers du rugby enfl mais
euh euh les différentes parties
prenantes parce que parce que il est pas
rare quand en Top 14 ou dans d'autres
compétition lorsqu'un un joueur est
contré euh de de sur une transformation
de voir l'arbitre renvoyer euh tout le
monde à la fois le buteur et le contreur
dans son camp en
disant on re on retape euh là là aucun
moment ça s'est posé il y a pas eu
d'appel à la à la vidéo il y a dans
l'esprit de l'arbitre jamais enfin même
Ramos pas rallé hein même Ramos pas ralé
parce que lui il était concentré il a
pas regardé non il a pas pu voir non
mais je vais vous dire ce qui ce qui
nous chagrine il y a plusieurs choses
qui nous chagrine j'esère que l'équipe
de France est perdue oui mais c'est que
notre ennemi héréditaire lui est
qualifié l'Angleterre ouais mais oui
mais c'est
çaenir ils étaient faibles on les a
batttu on les a écrasé on avait le
plaisir de se dire on va les retrouver
en demi-finale et on va les écraser n
vousz RA par dans après il y autre chose
qui embête nous nos autres amis aussi
pas moi là mais c'est que tous les
points ont été marqués par des
Toulousains moi ça me ravit mais je
comprends que ça puisse en je dis ça
pour faire sourire un
peuz si vous arrivez à trouver des
satisfactions personnelles car j'en suis
ravi pour vous mon très cher Carl tiens
Jean-Marc Vincent allez si on doit
donner trois joueurs qui ont été bons
qui ont surnagé et trois joueurs qui ont
failli après ce match et on va tous y
passer allez-y Jean-Marc vous avez la
main évidemment Cyril B dans les dans
les bons movaka Cyril
[Musique]
B pardon Flam 2G ouais je flamant je
suis plus partagé moi Jalibert fait fait
je trouve quand même qu'il fait des
actions accès
exceptionnel sur certains certaines
actions il fait oublieramac je dis pas
qu'entam est jeté à la poubelle bien
s'en faut mais mais jaliber a démontré
qu'il avait
il avait le talent d'attaque non mais je
sais il est pas toulousain excuse-moi
mais il a fait alors effectivement mais
la faute de défense elle est partagée
par fikou et sur le sur sur le le trou
pris par un un Sud-Africain Jalibert et
fikou partage la faute mais non non je
trouve que Jalibert a fait des coups et
des des des il a fait des percés des
petits par-dessus quand même il a été
pour les Sud-Africains un poison pendant
longtemps euh donc ça ça ferait pour les
pour les les bons points les mauvais
points effectivement il y a pour moi il
y a le 8 c'est aldrit est très en
dessous
euh fikou mais qui fait pas je sais plus
qu' a dit mais il fait pas une très
bonne Coupe du Monde et puis euh bielb
bien que s en fait disputé par le coach
euh ne prend vous remarquerz qu'il prend
très rarement son couloir il a tendance
à jouer au pied et en plus il tape trop
loin ce qui va dans les 22 m
occasionne un arrêt de volé des
défenseurs donc c'est un
ballon qume rir plusieurs fois au sur du
pont à un moment empêcher voyez que les
sudafricains jouent des touche
rapidement on l' pe vu offensivement
mais il a fait le boulot sur ce travail
de l'ombre
nonan a bien défendu je trouve ou voilà
allez-y Jean-Marc dans ce il a il a bien
défendu il a été au soutien tout ça est
vrai je me rappelle quand même qu'il
était lié et qu'il a et qu'il un début
c'est de faire des débordements des
quatrages débordement comme on sait
comme chacun de nous le sait et
là-dessus alors que quand vous le voyez
l'échauffement il a des jambes de feu ce
garçon et il les utilise pas quand il
est en attaque parfois il a un couloir
alors au niveau international le couloir
il est très étroit toujours mais on il
le prend très rarement c'est quand même
on continue à à faire notre évaluation
François cross la vérité c'est que l'on
est éliminé c'est dommage pour nous le
groupe est le public qui nous suit on n
rien lâché on avait mis les ingrédients
mais on a encaissé des points trop
facilement voilà ce que ce qu'il nous
dit François cross Mathieu jaliber c'est
compliqué de trouver les mots oui nous
on discute on discute mais lorsqu'on a
pris l'antenne nous aussi on a eu du mal
alors on imagine ce que ce qu'en pense
les joueurs oui ces joueurs derrière
alors on a parlé de Ramos longuement
c'est l'un des premiers joueurs qu'on a
évoqué le problème de ce jeu au pied
face au poteau mais Damien penau le
futur meilleur marqueur de l'histoire
des Bleus parce que ça va arriver un
jour ou l'autre pas vu pas prix hein
Carl non mais c'était pas un match pour
nos ailiers en fait ils ont pas eu
beaucoup de ballon ce que dit Jean-Marc
est très juste et quand ils en ont eu
ils ont tapé au pied au lieu d'essayer
de déborder mais bon point pour la
défense sud-africaine qui nous a empêché
euh qui a empêché nos ailiers de
d'attaquer et donc qui ont fait beaucoup
défendre et on sait qu'on perd quand
même beaucoup de d'énergie en défense
surtout face au
sud-africain moi ce que je note les
trois bons et trois moins bons c'est que
la la première mi-temps on a vu notre
première ligne rayonnante oui on citait
anonio bail avec trois essais trois
essais trois essais pr doublé de bail ça
et quand la la première ligne a changé
bah c'était une autre limonade
c'està-dire que on a pris des pénalités
on a pris des coups francs on a reculé
c'était plus la même sérénité et là
c'est étonnant parce que jusqu'ici quand
les finisseurs comme Galtier les Appell
rentrait sur le terrain on sentait pas
une baisse de niveau parfois même on
avait un petit supplément comme il y a
eu là pour les les Sud-Africains nous on
a senti là clairement une baisse de
niveau au moins sur la mêlée l'arbitrage
en rugby c'est comme les élections c'est
truqué ce que nous diten bon c'est
peut-être un peu excessif mais voilà et
caramel qui nous demande Colby est-il
parti avant pour contrer la
transformation alors on n pas encore vu
les images mais c'est ce qu'on me dit
dans l'oreillette et visiblement
certains l'ont analysé je donne le
résultat de notre petite consultation la
blessure d'Antoine Dupont a-t-elle
influé sur le résultat du match non à 72
%s pensent que Antoine Dupont était au
top voilà en tout cas la
majorité quand on connait le jeu
d'Antoine Dupont on voit bien qu'il
était pas au top il était bien en
première mi-temps
mais on voyait qu'il pass le ballon
quiessayait pas de franchir à fond sauf
le la la pénalité qui joue rapidement
mais en faisant la passe et la deuxième
mi-temps non c'était pas l'Antoine
Dupont qu'on a connu alors est-ce que
c'est parce qu'il était fatigué est-ce
que parce que le 5 8 de devant était mal
mené dans les RCK les molles ce qu'on a
dit mais le fait est c'était pas le même
autonne du pont que qu'on a connure
évaluation qui a été bon oui vous avez
un mot sur du pont non non je voulais
justement qui a été bon qui s'est manqué
Laurent lou alors moi je voudrais qui a
été bon je voudrais en faire d'abord un
la première ligne je voudrais la
première première ligne mention spéciale
mention spéciale sur les trois les trois
de la première ligne avant avant leur
avant leur sortie ensuite j'ai peut-être
pas vu le match que tout même match que
tout le monde et moi j'ai trouvé Cameron
wy avait été présent tout au long du
match voulez que je vous rappelle son
erreur sur le premier essai voulez que
je vous rappelle son ballon qui n'est
pas gratté à 2 m de la ligne en première
mi-temps bon attendez Laurent vous
rigolez ou quoi j'allais vous dire
j'allais vous dire une chose oui
j'allais vous dire
que j'allais vous dire que si on avait
pas eu cameroni aujourd'hui euh en
touche je sais pas si on aurait pu en
première mi-temps être aussi parfois
flamboyant qu'on qu'on l'a été parce que
il a été notre principal pourvoyeur en
touche et ça a été très précieux
donc je trouve je trouve que c'est pas
voilà et puis derrière je trouve que
Dany euh a été également jusqu'à la fin
du match euh extrêmement vol
je n'ai qu'un regret et c'est le seul
bémol que je mets dans sa prestation il
a été il a été volontaire en attaque
très présent en défense mais il a pas
été le gratteur de ballon qu'on a
l'habitude de voir d'ordinaire moi je
l'aurais mis justement justement pour ça
je le mettais dans dans les trois dans
moi je vais te donner les tris TR par
que me les demandait pour moi c'est la
faillite des CADR et ces cadres se
nomment évidemment aldrit devant
évidemment Dupont parce que s'il a été
bon en première mi-temps au moment où il
fallait faire la différence et notamment
quand Declerc qui rentrait il a perdu
son match son face- àf face à Declerc et
il a pas su trouver les clés pour
inverser la tendance c'était sa mission
celle que lui avait confié Galtier et
celle que tous les autres joueurs du 15
de France attendaient de lui et puis
3ème Ramos parce qu'il a laissé frapper
des points au pied et et comme buteur et
sans l'accabler lui précis mais c'est la
responsabilité qu' prend euh je lance le
la dernière question et ce sera notre
dernier débat ici qui va gagner la coupe
du monde vous voulez pas que je vous
donne mes ah si si pourquoi pas mais
bien sûr mais attendez je je lance le
sondage et je vous donne la parole
François je ne vous avais certainement
pas oublié qui va gagner cette coupe du
monde et bien c'est bien simple
Angleterre l'Afrique du Sud l'Argentine
ou la Nouvelle-Zélande je vois évoluer
le sondage c'est assez intéressant
François allez rapidement votre top 3
top flop et
top un joueur dont on a pas parlé et et
je suis assez curieux parce que je l'ai
trouvé très bon en première mi-temps il
a eu un peu baiss de rythme en en 2è
c'est Charles Olivon ou je l'ai trouvé
très bon fait je l'ai trouvé vraiment
très bon je l'ai trouvé sur tous les
points de rendez-vous je trouvé en
soutien euh
movaka et toute la première première
première ligne c'est vrai euh moi j'ai
un bémol sur effectivement sur peno
parce que peno là non plus a pas fait de
différence et et il est c'est la
deuxième étoile des Bleus on le dit
souvent non ouais mais il est rentré
tout le temps il est rentré tout le
temps à l'intérieur il a il le le le de
toute façon le avant dans les 10
dernières minutes la trè ligne la trème
ligne l'a pisté il a il a pas pu se
dégager et puis euh à vouloir toujours
décadrer sortir de c'est sa qualité
première de de de sortir de du jeu et
d'aller et je pense pas que c'était le
jour pour sortir de jeu en tout cas en
deuxième mi-temps c'était pas c'était
pas là c'est là où on va perdre des
points et puis denti à mon avis
effectivement d'ti gratteur de ballon
d'ti point de fixation de l'attaque et
ben là je l' trouveré en difficulté mon
denti quel avenir pour les Bleus
rapidement Jean-Marc Gonin est-ce qu'il
va falloir faire du changement est-ce
qu'on continue comme ça parce que mine
de rien depuis que Galtier est arrivé
c'estes 80 % de réussite et on ne peut
pas tout balayer sur un match perdu d'un
point ou est-ce que non il va falloir
trouver des solutions changer des choses
Jean-Marc à la marche probablement il y
a des il y a des finisseurs il y a des
remplaçant qui éta qui ont démontré
qu'ils étaient pas au niveau dans les
dans les matchs de groupe l'équipe celle
qu'on a vou vu évoluer ce ce soir me
semble me semble à la hauteur d'accord
sur la remarque sur la deè la deuxième
première ligne si je peux m'exprimer les
finisseurs de première ligne qui n'ont
pas été au niveau mais tout ça assees
limite parce qu' c'est aussi l'Afrique
du Sud qui était en face et il y avait
aussi une première ligne sudafricaine
toute fraîche et vous savez comment ils
sont c'est pas facile de d'être en face
voilà je mais autrement franchement je
vois pas galetier changer
reprendre son son sa sa copie avec une
copie blanche ça ça m'étonnerait cette
équipe fonctionne elle a elle ils
s'entendent bien ils travaillent bien
ensemble de toute façon il va y avoir
des changements dans le staff puis que
Laurent Labit s'en va que Karim guzal
s'en va ils vont aller entraîner le
Stade Français donc il va y avoir
forcément des des changements je on peut
pas dire grandir des joueurs VI le
Barret par exemple grandir des joueurs
peut-être travailler alors je sais
qu'ils avaient deux psychologues
travailler encore leement
et puis voilà la défense on peut pasaned
a fait un boulot magnifique là on est
obligé de lu rendre hommage donc on
continue non mais on peut le dire on a
perdu mais peut-être qu'il faut
continuer on peut pas tout jeter de
toute façon vousz rappé il y a eu 80 %
de victoire ENF
jle il y a 4 ans c'était ce que
rappelait Françis Obel les défaites
encour parle deado pas
d'ailleurs pas très encourageante
c'était la langue de bois qu'on nous
servait en dis non mais c'est des
défaites encourageantes parce que il y a
des promesses à fois là on a 80 % de
victoire puis on a construit quelque
chose de toute façon pas Jer Laur C
cette élimination en quart de finale de
Coupe du monde à la maison est un échec
oui d'un un échec d'un petit point pour
un coach qui a inversé la tendance ces
qu dernières années dans un contexte
général de fédéral extrêmement compliqué
puisquil faut quand même souvenir que à
côté de lui enfin en tout cas audessus
de lui dans la pyramide fédérale le
départ de la porte et dans des
conditions qu'on la porte il dit que
c'est lui que c'est grâce à lui que tout
ça est
arrivé évidemment pu vous posez la
question de Thib évidemment qu'on laisse
les clés à Galtier d'acord non oui ça ça
je pense que la question se posit pas
trop mais il va falloir faire des
ajustements d'autant plus que la semaine
dernière souvenez-vous on disait quatre
équipes du Sud affrontent quatre équipes
du Nord potentiellement on pourrait
avoir des demi-finales avec les quatre
équipes du Nord Nord le résultat ce soir
c'est qu'on a trois équipes du Sud en
demi-finale et une seule équipe du Nord
qui n'est en plus pas la plus forte et
dont on imagine on verra votre sondage
que c'est peut-être pas elle qui sera en
finale conf sondage sous les yeux France
a perdu mais l'Irlande qui est numéro 1
a aussi perdu pays de gale c'est
peut-être moins surprenant mais voilà ça
veut dire que le nord c'est peut-être vu
trop beau c'est-à-dire que le Nord a
peut-être gagné des matchs contre
l'hémisphère sud dans des matchs de
préparation dans des tournées mais c'est
quand c'est le moment de la coupe du
monde et ben les blacks sont là
peut-être pas le match d'ouverture mais
le match àisation direct ils sont là les
sudafricains sont là ils ont perdu un
match de pool alors tout le monde disit
ah les matchs de pool ils ont perdu
c'est plus cux oui sauf qu'ils sont là
et c'est pourtant une équipe
vieillissante on le rappelait au début
de la Coupe du monde ils sont âgés ça
oui mais vous le disiez Tib ils ont
l'expérience et ils sont là était
là qui sauve le match white lock le le
vétéran de des c'est pas vous Carl sur
Non je vois que vous avez pas votre
portable dans les mains Carl sur Youtube
qui commente il me fait rire comme d'hab
ça va chialer sur l'arbitre alors que ça
rattrape pas une chandelle
voilà bon jeanmon Vincent roseron
dites-nous qui va gagner cette coupe du
monde il est 23h50 vous êtes toujours
devant le Stade de France il fait
bientôt moins 10 degr
ouz vous avez l'air bien avec vos
petites doudoun et tout non vous êtes
bien je vous vois bon allez dites-nous
rapidement qui va être champion du monde
alors pour moi je pense que ce serait la
je vois la Nouvelle-Zélande puis que
alors c'est plus du tout la même équipe
que celle qu'on a affronté en ouverture
clairement on le voit
bien on a gagné très logiquement face à
elle en match d'ouverture là le match
contre l'Irlande ça n'avait absolument
rien à voir il y a eu beaucoup de cadres
qui sont revenus moi je pense que la
Nouvelle-Zélande va remporter ce ce mond
en tout cas ils sont favoris aujourd'hui
pour moi je partage votre avis moi je on
a retrouvé des All Blacks plein de
créativité énorme soutien enfin on a
retrouvé les All Blacks moi je les
enterrai un peu quelqu'un vient de dire
on pensait qu'il car je crois j'étais de
ceuxl qui disaent ils sont vieillissants
les boxes sont vieillissants mais là il
le poids de l'expérience et puis pour ne
citer qu'un qu'un joueur Aaron Smith que
que je trouvais très en dessous dans
dans les championnats du Sud il a été il
a été remarquable et là maintenant en
plus ils vont réaffronter l'Afrique du
Sud qui leur avait mis énormément de
point en match en match de préparation
peut-être s'il tombent contre eux en
finale ils auront très envie de le je
sais je sais on va pas passer les
demfinal de points pour la la
nouvellezé le Stade de France merci
messieurs je vous libère je sais qu'il
fait froid Jean margonin mille merci
d'être venu au micro avec Vincent Ros
pour nous portez votre analyse je suis
content parce que vous repartez avec le
sourire quand vous êtes arrivé tout à
l'heure vous aviez presque une petite
lar JeanMarc
ouais oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais bon voilà c'est c'est du rugby
moi je suis toujours content et j'irai
voir les les les trois derniers matchs
avec le plus grand plaisir et vous êtes
bien chanceux j'espère que vous
reviendrez derrière ce micro allez on
continue ici on finit Laurent Louette
qui va gagner cette coupe du monde vous
avez quatre choix il y a 15 jours
j'étais au Royaume-Uni et dans la presse
dans la presse anglaise était écrit
texto la the worst team of England la
pire équipe d'Angleterre de rugby donc
je ne crois je n'y crois je suis comme
mes confrères britanniques je n'y crois
pas un instant C équip d'accord vous
éliminez les Anglais j'élimine les
Anglais je pense que les blacks ne vont
faire qu'une
bouchée des Argentins alors il reste
plus que de alors il en reste plus que
deux et donc je vais rester sur les All
Black qu'on a peut-être battu dans notre
finale au premier tour mais oui hein je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez car je
vous avais dit ça on les bat on sera pas
champion du monde j'avais eu un comme ça
ou c'est vrai ou Carl vous qui sera
champion du monde bah je vois bien je
note qu'il y a TR points pour l'instant
pour la Nouvelle-Zélande je vois bien
une finale Nouvelle-Zélande Afrique du
Sud oui vous êtes pas très original non
non mais en même temps je vous demande
d'être précis d'être plus précis oui je
réfléchis parce que je vois les BLS
parce qu'ils vont être revchard parce
qu'ils sont pris une humiliation dans ce
match de préparation face au
sud-africain et que les Blacks n'aiment
jamais perdre et donc ils vont vouloir
se venger surtout avec un tel écart non
moi les BL les blackes sans surprise que
j'ai vu hier résister à 11 minutes de F
irlandaise 11 minutes avec combien 36
non combien 37 phases ouais 32 32 ou 33
ouais phase de jeu ouais franchement
tenir comme ça en défense
avec un Sam kan qui a été d'une
efficacité redoutable toute la trèg
d'ailleurs a été d'une efficacité
redoutable non je je vois pas comment
ils peuvent perdre cette coupe du monde
alors vous voulez le résultat de mon
sondage ouais l'équipe qui est la moins
en vue chez nos internautes c'est
l'Angleterre avec 6 % ouais vient
l'Argentine 7 % ouais l'Afrique du Sud
42 et la Nouvelle-Zélande 45 c'est plus
serré que sur notre plateau ou après le
match de ce soir les internautes pensent
que l'Afrique du Sud pas mais parce que
ils ont l'art de pourrir le le le le le
jeu de l'adversaire et c'est c'est ça
c'est leur grande qualité c'est c'est
ils l'ont prouvé ce soir et peut-être
que c'est là où ça va se jouer ouis fait
on on dit tous la Nouvelle-Zélande parce
qu'on a été impressionné par leur match
hier parce que on les attendit
honnêtement on les on les attendait pas
à ce niveau-là ce qu'ils ont fait dans
préparation et dans les phases de poule
on n'imaginait pas on les voit là donc
après il faut reproduire ce niveau de
match face aux Argentins c'est pas très
compliqué mais face aux
Sud-Africains les Sud-Africains en
revanche ils sont à leur niveau au
niveau auquel on les attendait je lis ce
que nous dit Olivier quand même et je
pense que ça conclut parfaitement ce
live les Sud-Africains n'ont rien montré
à part leur brallon dans les mêlé et
avec les arbitres voilà ce qu'ils nous
disent bon on a des anthanes piquants
merci messieur mais merci merci on est
déçu forcément mais on a essayé de
garder le sourire on suivra évidemment
la fin de cette coupe du monde sur le
figero live nous verrons qui deviendra
champion du monde pour l'instant vous
chers internautes vous pensez que c'est
la Nouvelle-Zélande qui s'imposera au
Stade de France dans dans 15 jours
peut-être peut-être nous verrons merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi merci à toute
l'équipe en régie autour de Sacha baudui
Augustin Morot romain rivraud tout le
monde était là pour mettre en place
cette cette grande soirée qui se termine
par une des illusions elle n'est pas que
petite elle est immense cette
désillusion mais on reviendra dans 4 ans
bonne
soirée